thank you all very much  thanks oh I don't know about that  is too much being made of this I think  so I don't have any special insight into  whether Joe Biden is or isn't going to  run if you had asked me nine months ago  I would have said I think Joe Biden is  definitely not running for reelection  today I think it's much more likely that  he will run for re-election and part of  this has to do with legislative  achievements uh approval rating recovery  circumstantial elements to this there's  a lot of different reasons but I'm  separating my opinion from what we saw  there I think it is just as likely  as what Joe Biden meant was  this isn't the venue in which we're  going to talk about my campaign because  we're here for the tribal Nation Summit  that would be consistent with Joe  Biden's personality and his kind of  modus operandi  um I think it's just as likely that it's  that as it is Joe Biden saying I don't  know that I'm going to be running